[Music]
Tyrese Gibson kicked this feud with Fast
& Furious co-star Dwayne Johnson into
high gear
these guys are Titan Disposal the 38
year old actor took to Instagram on
Wednesday to share this seemingly
fun-loving photo with his co-stars but
don't let that smile fool you Tyrese
revealed his true feelings for Johnson
aka agent hub and his fast and furious
spin-off in the caption writing I'm
sorry to announce that if Dwayne is in
Fast 9 there will no more Roman peers
what I do
he then seemingly called out Johnson's
chiseled physique as being the result of
steroid use and called the actors
selfish when what matter most is just
making a great movie so that really
that's the most important thing and I
think as long as you can keep that
perspective in mind then I think all the
other stuff kind of just has a way of
working itself out now as for the future
of the franchise a source tells ET they
could absolutely right out Gibson's
character adding that they're
hard-pressed to get Dewayne back into
fast 9 so it's kind of moot the source
says shooting probably won't begin until
2019 and just weeks ago series star
Jordana Brewster told et this about the
delayed sequel no updates on my end but
you know it's just it's not it's not
that crazy delay and I don't know there
are there always other iterations that
can come about service II